qu'est-ce qui vous rend vers de rage
pédophilie
touriste sexuel
soirée on a parlé beaucoup politique ce
soir
des titres
les spectateurs vont penser à une
maladie de la peau avant parce que vous
croyez qu'ils savent plus que c'est
que le Jospin a été accusé dit-on
le scoop c'est que il faisait partie de
ma cellule ah c'est vrai ça
non regardez vous voyez non mais c'est
vrai ou c'est pas vrai et je revois ce
blondinet
et je me souviens que sur les barricades
en mai 68 il avait seulement un problème
c'est que quand on lui disait va là-bas
à gauche il allait à droite
donc j'ai connu un Jospin j'ai connu
réellement c'était lui ou son frère
alors voilà j'en suis au même point de
vue ah oui d'accord vous avez connu un
jeu Spain trots on sait pas si c'est
Lionel Messenger
on va parler de votre spectacle
qui s'appelle Alex Mehdi et perd la tête
au palais royal jusqu'au 31 décembre
2000 c'est très drôle c'est un cours de
médecine humoristique c'est ça c'est le
c'est le travail des hormones sur le
désir la jalousie la colère j'ai voulu
faire un cours magistral déconnant
illustré par des sketchs c'est à dire je
suis un professeur qui s'adresse au
public et je suis parti de donner
scientifique exacte sur les hormones le
travail de nos organes dans l'amour dans
la haine dans la dans la jalousie je
fais donc un cours
qui surprend au début et une fois que
les gens sont rentrés dedans alors c'est
formidable parce que tout d'un coup il y
a une espèce de connivence scientifique
avec le public et on s'aperçoit que le
public est beaucoup plus intelligent
qu'on imagine toujours c'est à dire
qu'il y a une sorte de connaissance
qu'on doit peut-être d'ailleurs à la
télévision je sais pas parce que cette
grande maison de la culture sur laquelle
on tape il y a il y a quand même un fond
de culture quand même et voilà donc ce
spectacle là qui s'appelle Axp par la
tête est basée sur des données
scientifiques le comportement hormonal
de l'homme quoi
toutes nos passions sont faites du
uniquement à des phénomènes hormonaux ce
qu'on imagine venir de notre âme en fait
ça vient de la mécanique voilà et alors
j'ai appris des choses très
intéressantes par exemple que quand
l'homme fait l'amour
il dégage une odeur suave s'affaire
sourire je suis sûr que les femmes en
soi illégal qui s'apparente à l'odeur du
bois de santal ah bon prouver c'est donc
des données scientifiques qui sont à la
fois drôles et à la fois juste et le je
crois que le public crie à cause de
cette connivence entre la réalité et
puis bon délire et seulement le problème
c'est que ça nous ramène un peu vers des
vers des grands primates quoi ça nous
ramène un peu vers des vers des grands
singes savez-vous que que quand on est
en colère qu'un mec qui tend bagnole qui
est en colère il a exactement les mêmes
hormones que un chimpanzé qui veut
devenir le maître dans le groupe
c'est-à-dire que on se trouve avec toute
une série d'hormones dans les dans nos
actions qui sont exactement celles du
monde animal alors vous dites que la
science-fiction finalement est un peu en
retard sur la vraie science parce que
l'explosion de la science est beaucoup
plus étonnante finalement aujourd'hui
que tout ce que peut nous raconter la
science-fiction oui et surtout il y a
une donnée de la science-fiction que
j'aime pas du tout qui est la donnée
pessimiste c'est-à-dire toute la
science-fiction est basée sur des
données des projections qui sont chemise
qui sont
plutôt noirs alors que ce qui se passe
avec la science j'ai pas l'impression
que ça soit ça exactement vous êtes un
optimiste donc
autrement je serai pas trop de ski
évidemment vous êtes toujours trop de
ski mais au Prix du Muguet il va pas
bouger
dans votre jeunesse mais vous êtes
toujours trop de ski non euh
ça serait ça serait une malhonnêteté de
ma part de dire et vous le savez que
pour être un militant il faut il faut
avoir beaucoup de temps il faut passer
du temps mais si vous voulez parler de
mes convictions qui sont celles qu'il y
a un changement nécessaire inévitable
oui en ce sens-là alors vous devez
trouver que le Parti communiste de
Robert Hue est pas du tout bien parce
qu'ils sont drôlement libéraux
maintenant c'est le copain de Jacques
Brel c'est de oui ben nous sommes pas
tout à fait sur la même longueur d'onde
autrement je serai au PC évidemment mais
c'est vrai que il arrive qu'on se
retrouve
il arrive qu'on se retrouve par quelques
aléas bizarres parfois sur la même
longueur d'onde mais non vous pensez
quoi du virage du PC depuis Robert
huguesespérée d'exister je crois que
c'est une tentative d'exister mais je ne
pense pas que ça soit dit à partir
révolutionnaire ni un parti à partir du
moment où vous êtes dans le gouvernement
et que vous cautionnez l'édition la
différence par exemple entre ce que
disent les socialistes aujourd'hui nous
sommes au gouvernement avec eux quand
ils disaient qui refusent la société de
marcher mais qu'ils acceptent la formule
socialiste disent ça le Premier ministre
elle a dit ça veut dire qu'il veut
réguler le marché capitaliste le système
capitaliste et bien moi comme communiste
j'ai pas envie de me contenter de le
réguler j'ai envie de le dépasser voilà
donc là on est tout ça dans des petites
nuances bien subtiles bien on va
regarder en tous les cas ce que vous
faites au Théâtre du Palais-Royal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça doit être pour toi viens je décroche
ou quoi
allô allô
parler plus fort j'entends pas parler
plus fort
c'est toi mais tu es folle de téléphone
et la maison le dimanche mais ma femme
est à côté elle est dans le jardin à
côté laisse-moi te parler regardez bien
sûr
c'est du faux
je te signale en particulier que je dis
je passe une visite médicale dans le
quartier de l'étoile je serai libre
jusqu'à 16h on pourrait se retrouver
chez Marcel et c'est d'avoir la clé s'il
n'a pas la clé c'est d'avoir
un message
fait fonctionner 14 muscles tous
ensemble ah oui ensemble il suffirait
qu'un seul n'obéisse pas bon
je voudrais remercier Monsieur le Député
Maire de joie la ville
qu'il a fait installer une usine de
traitement de déchets nucléaire au
village
il faudrait également que tu me trouves
un costume civil et des papiers
qui rencontrent un vieux copain qui l'a
pas vu depuis des années alors là on
peut dire qu'on est à la limite de la
débilité
[Rires]
tu m'attendras avec ses provisions au
coin de l'avenue de Wagram et de la
Place de l'Étoile
entre 18h et 19h si j'ai du retard
t'inquiète pas c'est que j'ai des prises
dans les embouteillages par contre si je
ne suis pas là 21h ne m'attends plus
brefs
surtout les la peau bleue avec les yeux
rouges
comme elle dit maman c'est dur de
l'habiller
après la fête je le raccompagne chez lui
et voilà devant sa porte il se met à
discuter dans la bagnole deux plans
et je peux dire que deux plantes de
conneries ça fait de la buée
il est évident qu'un homme qui passe la
journée du samedi à déboucher les vieux
tendre le gazon et faire une grosse
machine de linge sale et droguée
pour une fois que c'est facile
on mange des produits naturels de la
campagne
des œufs
[Applaudissements]
au Théâtre du Palais Royal
ça se passe bien ça se passe très bien
bien alors vous aussi donc je disais
depuis le début de la soirée avec des
fils de militaire il y a vous il y a
Charles Berling vous votre père était
radio navigant lui il était radion
navigant il s'était un personnage assez
extraordinaire puisque il était à la
fois ce militaire et il était à la fois
cet homme de théâtre qu'il a toujours
fait au noir puisqu'il en tant que
militaire il avait pas le droit de 500
et j'ai deux jours toujours connu mon
père en Algérie quand on était à Alger
Blida Constantine je l'ai connu beaucoup
plus souvent sur la scène sous un faux
noms de ma société je lis beaucoup plus
connu comme ça que au poste de pilotage
c'est à dire que c'était un homme assez
extraordinaire qui a réussi à mener une
carrière double pendant toute son
existence alors celui qui vous a donné
le virus du spectacle de la de la
musique évidemment parce que vous alliez
avec lui vous emmener avec lui donc
j'ai fait je devais avoir 10 ans et je
l'ai fait pour des militaires qui
partaient en campagne alors vous débutez
on va pas raconter toute votre vie mais
enfin parce que celle de def ce soir
tellement plus important
et donc vous débutez à 17 ans comme
musicien de jazz et vous faites vos en
fait vos débuts de comics sur scène
c'est en 75 au Blanc-Manteau alors on
sait pas quel âge j'avais parce que vous
refusez de dire votre âge vous vous
écris c'est quelque chose on est classé
on est classé
encore dans ce mais c'est pas à cause
des femmes non non je suis je suis casé
d'abord j'ai perdu beaucoup de temps
avec les femmes oui c'est à dire que je
peux dire que pendant près de de de 10
ans 10-15 ans c'était beaucoup plus
important de vivre une vie romanesque
pas dans le sens pas mais essentiel
il fallait qu'il y ait du romanesque
dans la vie et je l'ai vécu dans la vie
avant de le transposer après sur scène
ouais non vous êtes toujours fait passer
l'amour avant l'ambition avant cette
idée d'arrivisme de se faire une place
de voilà maintenant c'est fini non
maintenant j'ai un petit garçon qui a 7
ans je suis avec une jeune femme qui est
plus jeune que moi
non non
je vais vous faire une petite interview
est-ce qu'on peut baisser la lumière
en la bouche fin pendant le Jing
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la semaine prochaine bien alors ces
quatre questions
qu'est-ce qui vous rend vers de rage
pédophilie
tourisme
qu'est-ce qui vous rend rouge de honte
quand je me marre en scène c'est à dire
quand moi-même faisant un spectacle je
suis pris par le rire d'un spectateur
être reconnu dans la rue par un
raconteur d'histoire
qui m'entreprend et je vous parle d'une
histoire arrivée c'est à dire Beaubourg
Odéon avec un mec alors c'est un type
qui rentre dans un café alors l'autre
histoire
c'est ma terreur qu'est-ce qui vous
rendez
mon petit garçon
c'était l'interview Technicolor et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de innarditube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu